à sainte-thérèse le festival santa
teresa bat son plein et il suscite
l'enthousiasmé même s'il a lieu à
l'intérieur cette année vraiment ça fait
tellement longtemps que je me rappelle
plus de la sensation en ce qu on veut
juste avoir encore on a encore plus faim
après le festival santa teresa dès le 25
juin le gouvernement du québec
autorisera le retour des grands
festivals extérieurs mais à certaines
conditions
la distanciation physique sera de
rigueur mais il peut avoir des pastilles
au sol justement pour s'assurer que ceux
de mettre le soin soit soit respectée
ceux qui désireront faire des spectacles
les spectacles à l'extérieur devront
avoir l'aval de l'accc de la santé
publique devrait avoir le feu vert de la
santé publique devront soumettre leurs
plans
plusieurs festivals garde le cap sur la
programmation déjà prévu mais avec la
possibilité d'accueillir jusqu'à un
maximum de 2500 personnes réparties aux
ondes
on devra donc revoir l'aspect logistique
cet été en fait le grand de la
programmation va sortir en juin
mais ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'on
va avoir différents éléments différente
si vite et qu'on pourra en faire non pas
que ce soit d'une dizaine d'activités
répartis un peu partout
c'est même possible qu'on décide d'en
rajouter six nations
en temps normal il y à plus de 250
festivals petits et grands au québec il
y en aura moins cette année mais à
baie-saint-paul la tête du sac
on sera prêt non en fait on faisait
partie des festivals téméraires on avait
déjà annoncé notre programmation et on a
vendu à une res 40 billets sur les onze
mille qu'on avait vendu et quelques
jours mais il reste quand même des des
petites des petites des petits détails
au niveau du service de bar au niveau de
la capacité des sites de distanciation
des festivals comme celui de
petite-vallée pourrait profiter des
récentes annonces et puis de bain les
gens à votre groupe lui doivent inciter
à venir
ils savent qu'ils vont pouvoir se
promener d'une zone à l'autre favori dit
il faudra oublier cet été la venue
d'artistes internationaux majeurs à
montréal les francos il a fait ce sera
de jazz ont été repoussé au mois de
septembre en mode écourtée et hybrides
pour plusieurs festivaliers l'important
est d'abord et avant tout de se
retrouver ensemble ici oui mais du
canada